strangers on a Florida beach are being
praised for banding together in a
life-saving rescue dozens of beachgoers
formed a human chain to reach nine
people trapped by dangerous Riptide in
the Gulf of Mexico
mark Strassmann is in Panama City Beach
Florida where that dramatic rescue took
place mark good morning good morning
these Gulf waters look fairly calm right
now but that's just how people remember
these same waters looking when this
Beach was in crisis a dangerous Riptide
lurked just offshore and suddenly the
heads of nine people were bobbing in the
water desperate for help they got it
they had told us they were drowning so
it kind of scared me
Jessica Simmons stepped up in a crisis
because somebody had to we have people
from the fog run into us she saw people
overmatched by a Riptide 100 yards off
shore they kept yelling at us like help
us help us we can't do it we can't do it
did you know they were in trouble yes I
knew they were in trouble
brothers Noah and Stephen Murray were
the first two people trapped in 15 feet
of water Roberta
Murray is their mother I seen my husband
my mama my oldest daughter and my
youngest daughter and my nephew I didn't
see my boys they were screaming and
crying that they were stuck they
couldn't go nowhere
the ory family and other people swam out
to rescue the boys but they became
stranded too as this cell phone video
shows people on the beach linked arms to
form a human chain into the water
roughly 80 people at all then Jessica
Simmons and her husband Derek both
strong swimmers swam out and with the
help of a surfboard guided the victims
one by one to the human chain and safety
it scared the living daylights out of me
Tabitha Monroe and her wife Brittany
spent 20 minutes floundering in the
Riptide the water kept coming up over my
head it was getting to where I couldn't
even feel the ground so it was scaring
me I kept taking water in
this video shows Tabitha finally making
it to shore in fact all nine stranded
people survived including 67 year old
Barbara friends she had a heart attack
in the water and was rescued unconscious
she's also Roberta Marie's mother and
she's doing fine did you think all nine
we're gonna survive yes I knew they were
because I knew because I was gonna make
sure your watch don't look this isn't
gonna happen a beach full of strangers
responded in a moment of despair and
because they did nine people are alive
today we live in a world where we have
so much going on around us and
everybody's always battling each other
every politics and races and different
like that but I'll tell you that was
over 20 different races on this beach
and they came together like that all the
lifeguards have gone home police were
here but we're waiting for a rescue boat
to show up people here on the beach knew
that people in the water we're running
out of time some of them have been
struggling in the water for a half hour
Noren Wow mark thank you so much I like
that it's a good example people are
working together all the time
pictures are stunning when you see and
they rescued all nine of them because I
think it's hard not to panic when you
get caught in a Riptide like oh yeah
and they're all okay stay calm and work
together go Jessica summons ya team good
story